hey everyone as many of you know i've
written several books but recently i had
the great privilege
of being the subject of a book in the
aussie
stem stars series stem being science
technology engineering
and maths this is kind of different to
the normal books that i've been involved
with because it's actually more like
a biography rather than a book about
mathematics the subject itself
and recently i had the chance to speak
with rebecca lim the wonderful author
of this book we had a chat and i hope
you get to watch it and enjoy it now
i'm really really pleased today to be
here with eddie wu to talk about this
book about eddie wu which is fantastic
it was a pleasure to work with him on
this
and um here's eddie rebecca thank you
so much for your time it's a real
pleasure to chat with you and i should
say thank you as well
um for creating this wonderful book it's
an incredibly well told story i feel a
privilege to be part of it
thanks okay now i've got a few questions
for you eddie um the first one is how
does it feel to have a book written
about your journey to becoming a math
teacher
yeah thank you rebecca it is really you
know when i think of a single word that
captures the entire experience it has to
be
surreal i actually remember um the first
time i picked up
my copy having you know spoken with you
many times and and thought about
okay what how are we going to tell this
story i i imagine you know
if i went in and watched a movie
someone's written a story and thought
okay who's going to be the characters
and
what arc are they going to go through
but this is very much
just reality and when i think back on my
own life
i don't think many people would
necessarily think oh yeah this would
make a great novel or something like
that
um but it is it is quite an amazing
thing to reflect back on
things that i've gone through in my life
um actually one of the eerie sort of
moments is uh you know some of the
illustrations which i love
um when i had a look through i was kind
of like whoa this is
it was kind of like yeah this is exactly
like uh you know me and my mom as she
tried to wake me up from school
i thought yes this actually really does
take me back and i hope that
the experience that people have reading
this is that they're encouraged
by the story of a very normal person uh
being able to
hopefully achieve things that help
people um just like everyone else is
capable of doing
so did you feel great emotions sort of
when you were reading about yourself and
looking at those pictures of
someone to pull them out of your head
yeah absolutely i think that for me
going back to some of my early childhood
um often
these are actually especially some of
the memories that i i didn't enjoy
particularly much when i was forming
them you know i don't actively
think back to those those days
frequently and to know that
those happened and they were a big part
of who my personality is and my
character and how that was formed
um yes it was an emotional journey to go
through that
but that actually prompts me to ask you
a bit of a question rebecca um
you know you're uh such a successful and
established author
and you've written so many different
kinds of things i guess i'm kind of
curious to know
what was it that made you want to write
a book in this series
and you know to write a book about
someone like me what was it that drove
and motivate you
well your stories um you know you
wouldn't think this but it's actually
still quite unique in
um fiction for non-fiction actually for
children and fiction for children
because stories about you know kids from
our background are still extremely rare
and i just wanted to get
you know an australian story which
didn't have the typical australian
character in it out there
and it's an inspiring story eddie like
you went through a lot of
you know like challenging times and
you've come out the other end and
may i say you're a superstar teacher so
to come through all the things that you
went through as a child
um and then to come out like this and
such a generous and giving person
you know you you could expect that
someone would actually go through
bullying for example and be really
closed off to the world
but it's kind of made you go the other
way so it was a really important story
to tell i think
no thank you wrecker that's an honor and
i do hope uh like you said
um it's so important that young people
growing up have a range of stories that
reflect
the wonderful diversity that we have in
australian culture
and we can kind of see it around us but
it is another thing to actually have
that
in text and in a way that people can
absorb and that they can
sort of inhabit this story and and
perhaps even see
part of themselves in the journey that
um you know whoever you know obviously
it's a great joy being part of this
series with others
um but there are some incredible people
who have belongs to
uh what we're celebrating through the
aussie stem stars that's right and i
think yeah the topics
not just the people i guess like there's
a very large spectrum of you know
different people
different scientists different um
technologists different you know maths
teachers
um stem professionals from different
backgrounds but um
yeah it's that whole range of you know
all the sort of subjects that a lot of
kids close themselves
off to really early and they find them
you know like they find like
maybe they've had one challenge and they
just closed themselves off to to doing
that for the rest of their lives but
um what you're trying to tell people
with your story is everyone can do maths
and so it's a really important um
story to get out there now the next
question i had for you is what do you
love most about
teaching maths i can think of a couple
of things in particular
and i feel very lucky that i've had the
opportunity to reflect on this so often
because
of course work in general is hard that's
why people get paid for it it's not easy
and teaching maths is no different there
are certainly things about it where i
think
hmm you know often when i walk into a
room especially if people have no idea
who i am i'm just
mr wheeler maths teacher maths is a
subject which does draw out a
particularly strong emotional response
from
most students and i should point out
usually a negative emotional response so
that for me is an enormous challenge
that's hard to ignore
but that's part of strangely what i love
because when i can have the time
like if i get to spend a year or two or
even more
with a student i'm seeing them day by
day and actually helping them develop
the skills and
the understanding to be able to say
actually i understand this i comprehend
it i can do things with this great new
power
that i've developed that's an incredibly
satisfying and gratifying moment to be a
part of
to enable a young person to develop
skills
and to solve problems that they would
have thought were impossible
otherwise to me that never gets old it's
why you know
14 years of teaching and i feel like i
am at the beginning of my career still
excited every day about walking
into the classroom so that's why the
first one i would say
yeah that freshness exactly and then the
second one is around
mathematics as a subject itself not just
about the teaching of it
but i i deeply believe that every
different uh
subject every key learning area it gives
us a lens
to understand and appreciate the world
around us
and mathematics is really special
because it's a language which is
literally
found everywhere it's in nature it's in
the built
environment what humans design is often
very patterned and geometric
and even you know in recent times living
through a global pandemic
mathematics has been one of the most
important tools that we have access to
to help us you know fight this virus and
be able to devise
effective measures to prevent disease so
to me
that's astonishing to give students
access to open this world and be able to
access those tools
that's pretty special i think and that's
part of what i love teaching about this
subject so much i mean that's a big
theme of the book and a big theme of
your life seeing the world in a
different way and i guess it's like a
superpower like once you
appreciate maths you start seeing it in
everything and you talk about that in
the book about how it's in you know
sport it's in carpentry it's in just
about every human endeavor so
yeah that's pretty amazing now the next
question i had for you is
um what are some of the most amazing
places that maths have led you to
hmm so this is a tricky question to
answer rebecca because
how much time do you have i certainly
didn't expect
um to go you know say to
dubai in the middle of the arab world to
represent
australia at the global teacher prize
where that prize was
1 million us dollars that was a definite
pinch me moment i can actually tell you
when i was there at the
um at the prize ceremony at the awards
ceremony and there were 10 of us there
up on stage um including a wonderful
woman named andrea zafaraku a textiles
and art teacher from the uk
who won that one million dollars and i
remember everything was just sort of
going along
as normal and then there was a hush that
went over the room and suddenly everyone
just went very still
and the the big royal family and rulers
of dubai and united arab era just walked
in with this enormous security
uh detail and i thought whoa okay this
is really serious
so moments like that definitely you know
you pinch yourself to be a part of them
but also for me and i'm thinking about
this actually this is my daily
work and i feel it's such a privilege to
be able to do it one of the things i
love most
is to be able to travel through parts of
our beautiful country
especially regional areas i i work
across new south wales
and i'm about to spend some time in the
riverina so that's kind of southwest new
south wales close to the victorian
border
being able to spend time supporting
students and teachers
parents everyone in the community to to
learn and to love maths
even though that may seem very everyday
it's not like
heading to you know another country or
something like that for me that's really
special because i get to interact with
these people who
have gone through incredible journeys
and sometimes who've gone through
incredible suffering
themselves and i get to play a small
role in encouraging them
and helping them learn so i love those
opportunities well that's fantastic yeah
we have been through
some terrible droughts and events in
this country so it's fantastic that you
can bring you know all your knowledge
out there
um where students can actually interact
with you i mean they feel like eddie's
already
their teacher because they can see you
on the screen but being able to see you
face to face is a whole different
experience um
next question was what are some of the
great tips for getting better at maths
because everyone can do maths right
that's the whole message of our book
well 100
and if there's anything that people take
away especially from reading the early
chapters of the book and knowing
where i came from and mathematics was
not really mainly my thing especially
when i was younger
it's that people should always and this
is one of the big lessons the big tips i
guess
they should always keep the door open i
think it's a
it's kind of obvious that there are some
things which we naturally
maybe have talent at and other things
where we kind of struggle along and for
me
it was like a really big light bulb
moment to realize
that in fact even if something doesn't
come naturally to us
being able to develop an understanding
and appreciation of that
idea or skill or area of knowledge is in
fact
all the more important so the first
thing i would say is kind of an
attitude thing right it's to say never
decide i'm going to close myself off i'm
going to shut that door forever
whether it's mathematics or reading or
science whatever it happens to be
to remain open to that and that does
mean you're going to have to struggle a
little bit sometimes and
that's part of the journey it's how
everyone who has learned something of
value
actually came to understand something
new so that's the first suggestion it's
an
attitude thing and then the second
suggestion is
for me i think that part of how i made
that journey from
not being very much into this
mathematical world not appreciating it
to
where i am today is kind of ironic it
seems like a chicken and egg problem
but one of the reasons why now i'm
fairly good at mathematics
is because i have forced myself over
hundreds and thousands of
hours to wrap my head around something
well enough
to explain it to others now at the
beginning
i was not very good at it but for me
it's such a
an embodiment of the truth that i
remember first learning from the
physicist richard feynman he said
you do not understand something truly
until you can explain it simply and so
my big tip i guess that comes out of
this is very practical
is if anyone wants to become better at
mathematics
and indeed better at many different
things my big tip is
take an idea a simple one one that
challenges you but isn't too complicated
and see if you can explain it to someone
else
not just like a peer who maybe is
learning the same thing at the same time
as you
but maybe someone younger or someone who
doesn't know very much about this
and because when you try to explain you
actually reveal to yourself
what do i know about this area and what
do i still need to
what gaps do i still need to fill in
which areas do i need to develop
that has happened to me countless times
as a teacher and it's what's forced me
to deepen my understanding by forcing
myself
to explain it to others so i help i hope
others can take up that tip
and get some practical value out of it
it's a great tip because i actually use
that in my own work as well like trying
to get really complex some ideas into
simple words that you know kids of
different ages can understand it's the
same you know technique so yeah i
completely understand that that's great
um now we have a throwdown challenge
which i think unfortunately i will
probably lose but let's have a go with
this and see how
fantastic i really appreciate you are
willing to uh give it a go with me
a lot of people not at all we're gonna
have a bit of fun together
and um yes i have a three-day challenge
for everyone who is watching and
the way it's gonna work is you and i
pick we're gonna play a game
uh and this game as people follow along
with the rules and they're very simple
rules
um even young children can play this
game and sometimes play it very well
um as they listen to the rules and see
us play the challenge is
for others to play this together so
generally you need kind of a buddy or a
friend or a parent or something like
that
to play this game with and i want you to
see if you can work
out how i did what i hope i'm about to
do and don't worry i'll repeat all the
details at the end here we go
so this game rebecca is called the game
of 23. it's one of my favorite games
it's very simple
um we're going to say numbers back and
forth according to certain rules
and um whoever gets to say the number 23
they're the winner okay that's that's
the goal so
if you get to say 23 you win and if i
get to say 23 i win okay
here's the way it works and um since you
know i'm i'm
explaining the rules to you rick i'll
let you start we're always going to
choose a number between
one and four and each time whatever
number we choose we're just going to
add it on it's going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and eventually one of
us is going to get to 23.
so i'll let you choose um one two three
or
four what number would you like to pick
i'm going to choose
okay a classic very good certainly don't
want to choose four okay that's fine
with me
all right so you've chosen three i'm
gonna go with i'm choosing the number
two
and you remember i said we're going to
add it on each time so that means the
number i reply back to you
is five following with me yeah okay so
again
you you have the choice between one and
four what would you like okay
um seven seven so okay you added two one
again
no problem okay um this time i'm going
to go with
um i'm adding on one so i'm going to say
eight okay
the do i have to tell you what i'm
adding one you can work it out no yeah i
can work it out so you just tell me what
the next number is
but you'll be fine
all right i'm going to go with 18.
ah so you added on to bring us to 20 i'm
gonna say
three so that i can have 23. okay
now well done rebecca you gave it a
really good shot i will i'll give you
credit for that and remember i know the
rules of this game
and well i've known the rules for this
game for a very long time and now
everyone who's watching also knows
now let me restate the challenge just
from the beginning right um
i won that game and i want it because
i knew something i sensed a pattern in
these numbers
um that was mostly invisible to you
or it was visible and you just played
along so
um the challenge to everyone is to work
out how did i do that
how did i ensure that i would win
because there's a very simple
mathematical pattern and i promise
anyone who can add numbers
up to one two three four right if you
can add on four um and
play this maybe maybe get a piece of
paper out um i encourage you to play a
few games um rebecca you you went first
that time if we were playing again i'd
go first and then we'd
go back and forth and i trust that
people will be able to work out
there are enough clues in the game that
if you know what you're doing
you can always win so i hope people have
a bit of fun with that
thank you for playing along with me and
i hope people out there can
take on the challenge and learn what
patton is hiding within this simple game
thanks so much eddie for speaking with
me today it's just a pleasure
you two rebecca i take the best of all
the best with this book
every school in the country and um
rebecca thank you
for putting such time and care and love
into writing this
it was a huge privilege to work with you
and be the subject of it so
thank you no worries